[Music]
hmmm looks like I'm going it alone this
week hey everybody I'm Walter bond
easyacc and this is top 5 you know what
my favorite movie series is well yeah
but after that it's back to the future
my love for these movies goes as far
back as I can remember from renting the
VHS copies at my local video store
dizzying the music score played live
with the first movie and everything in
between it's been quite the journey for
me doc and Marty and I know millions of
people all over the world feel the same
way this trilogy continues to be
immensely popular 28 years after the
release of the last installment comic
books video games and a cartoon series
carried on its legacy when I look back
at the original films though there are
so many moments that I have strong
memories attached to these moments made
the film's unforgettable and today we're
gonna look at my favorite ones these are
the top 5 best Back to the Future
trilogy moments
number five
[Music]
this was Biff at his most evil and also
produced one of my favorite images of
the series in this alternate 1985 we got
to see just how bad Biff could have
gotten if he had all the advantages this
is the worst case scenario as he pretty
much owns hill valley and everyone in it
another great scene earlier in part two
shows that George McFly was murdered in
Marty's reaction to finding his father's
tombstone is one of the darkest moments
in this trilogy all of that build-up
leads to Marty and Biff's confrontation
on the roof of his Hotel and Casino it's
here that we find out the truth about
George's death it couldn't match up the
bullet that killed your old man
suppose it's poetic justice to mix lies
with the same God Marty's leap off the
roof and the moment of suspense that
followed was so well done and just
hearing doc and Marty right after still
makes me smile
[Music]
I don't believe it I think Thomas F
Wilson has looked over too much in this
series we all love to hate him as 1955
Biff but he's so good as old man Biff
Griff and this ultimate evil version of
the same character he's also phenomenal
as Buford Tannen in Part 3 but this
moment of mocking the McFly legacy as he
stands as the king of Hill Valley is
possibly the character's best moment
number 4 your future is whatever you
make this is such a bittersweet scene
for me it's a great ending with a great
message and I absolutely love that doc
and Marty reunited one more time in 1985
they're one of the best on-screen duo
ever in my book and the ending to this
trilogy was really something special I
brought you a little souvenir
[Music]
we see that doc has had a family with
Clara and achieved his dream of
traveling all over time and how badass
is the time train what a cool idea as a
kid the reason this was bittersweet for
me was because one of my favorite movie
series was ending the story was told and
it was absolutely a complete trilogy but
I always wanted to see more and I wanted
to see the time train in action with Doc
Marty Clara Jules and Vern I didn't grow
up with the cartoon show so these films
were it for me for a long time luckily
there's no shortage of back to the
future content out there now and I've
enjoyed seeing more of the characters
anyway I could get them while Bob Gale
and Robert Zemeckis have repeatedly said
there will never be a Back to the Future
Part 4 it's good to know that they still
Revere this franchise and we'll put it
at risk with a subpar installment the
ending of the series still draws a
reaction from me and is definitely one
of the best moments in the trilogy and
yes I know about the kid in the
background number 3
[Music]
[Applause]
how this moment was built up was near
perfection I love the earth angel song I
love how the score swells I love Marnie
popping back up this is a trademark part
of the whole series and especially that
first movie there's not much more to say
about it it's just a great climax to one
part of the story and seeing George and
Lorraine fulfilled their destiny while
being better off because of Marty's help
had us all invested to the fullest
effect number two watch me for the
changes and try and keep up okay
[Applause]
[Music]
directly following our last moment is
the classic that everyone still talks
about Johnny be good now I could have
kind of the earth angel kiss and this as
the same moment but I think they're
distinctly different if the kiss is the
victory Johnny be good is the
celebration everything about this song
and performance by Michael J Fox screams
iconic while he didn't sing the song in
the final version he did mimic all the
guitar movements - exactly what was
being played during these few minutes
there are plenty of little jokes and
many moments that people love to discuss
[Applause]
[Music]
as Marty plays on he gets carried away
and eventually ends up rolling on the
floor kicking over an amp and totally
losing the crowd I love the looks the
starlighter's give Marty when he starts
going over the top and the shot of mr.
Strickland cupping his ears fantastic
Marty's line at the end of it sums up
this moment better than anything I could
say I can't kiss you guys aren't ready
for that yet but your kids are gonna
love it
so originally I had a ton of honorable
mentions but the truth is I love these
films so much that most of this series
would be honorable mentions
George punching Biff the tunnel chase
from Part 2 the Libyan seen flooding
Buford in part 3 pretty much everything
your favorite moments are my favorite
moments definitely let me know which
Back to the Future trilogy moments you
connect with most and the Comets in the
number one best Back to the Future
trilogy moment a three three Martin Kemp
- such a Back to the Future oh I know
you did send me back to the future but
I'm back I'm back from the future
[Music]
I still get chills when I watch that
part honestly everything from when the
time machine is struck by lightning to
the end of the movie can fit into this
spot let's start from there
marty has just burned the Almanac and
reset the future saving his father's
life in the process during the same
lightning storm that helped send Marty
back to 1985 in the first movie a flying
DeLorean doc is piloting is struck by
lightning and sends him back to the Old
West marty is left there in a terrifying
moment of hopeless uncertainty when the
Western Union mailman shows up to give
Marty Doc's letter we go from a glimmer
of hope to pure excitement seeing a
different perspective on the ending of
the first movie was so cool the whole
concept is a big reason why part two is
my personal favorite of the trilogy the
music's sudden urgency is Marty Sprint's
into frame is the definition of hype it
still gets me so excited to see the
final chapter and that emotional
rollercoaster of DOC disappearing Marty
reading the letter and finding 1955 doc
is my best moment of all three films
Great Scott I love these movies they
hold up so well and if it's been a while
since you've seen them find a couple
friends throw on a life preserver and
enjoy the ride this week on my personal
channel we keep this time train rolling
with my review of the Back to the Future
animated series this was actually the
first time I've seen any of the episodes
so head on over for a fresh take on the
show I want to hear what you guys think
what is your favorite Back to the Future
trilogy moment what do you want me to
cover next on the show leave a comment
and let me know to keep in touch you can
like my Facebook page facebook.com slash
awesome Walter B or follow along on
Twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future no way
that I could come up with a worst list
for this trilogy so we'll be back next
week with a brand new subject here on
top 5
[Music]
no worse Back to the Future moment say
well if he won't do it I will
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you